healthy on everybody so there have been
a few Lego leaks lately some of them
real some have been fake but it appears
that some real ones have actually
surfaced they appear to be real because
on whatever platform that some of these
pictures were posted on Instagram
Twitter reddit etc
they've all been removed and this really
only happens thanks getting taken down
when something gets out that Marvel
really didn't want to get out and what
actually got leaked that got out was a
location so it wasn't characters or new
costumes that got leaked in this Lego
set although the characters were wearing
the white suits that we've seen recently
which we believe to be suits for
traveling inside of the quantum realm
but we've known about that for a few
weeks now but what was really leaked
what these Lego set photos was the
quantum city this is huge news because
this reveals that this isn't just some
place that they're going to briefly
mention or a visit this is going to be a
pretty big deal in Avengers 4 also my
giveaway still continues I'm still
giving away copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
not too long ago we were told to look
closely at the scene where Hank Pym and
Janet Van Dyne leaved the quantum realm
and ant-man and the wasp well after
going over the scene very carefully and
freeze framing it
one fan found a whole entire city inside
of the quantum realm now we really
didn't know if this was going to play
any role in Avengers 4 or if it was
going to be in the next ant-man film but
this leaked Lego set seems to confirm it
for Avengers 4 so it's going to be very
important in Avengers 4 and Kevin Feige
even said that in an interview that
ant-man and the wasp is going to be very
important moving forward obviously using
the quantum realm for time-travel is
going to be very important but there's a
whole city inside of the quantum realm
who knows what or who could be in this
city Captain Marvel is said to be linked
to the quantum realm somehow
perhaps this could relate to her and
recently it has been discovered that
there could be a second villain in
Avengers for it that's an even greater
threat than Thanos many people believe
this villain to be Annihilus and
Annihilus is actually from the negative
zone which the MCU could very well turn
into the quantum realm so could an
eyeless or any potential second villain
be possibly hiding in this quantum city
and if so is this how they become the
second threat does Ant Man somehow run
into them when he's trapped inside the
quantum realm and somehow set them free
into earth obviously it's all
speculation right now but it's clear
that this quantum city and the quantum
realm are going to play a very important
part in Avengers 4 so let me know your
thoughts on this who or what do you
think is in this quantum city in the
quantum realm let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe comment and like the video
so you can enter the giveaway and stay
up to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]